welcome back to Hannity joining us now
with more reaction to this explosive new
document that Fox News obtained just a
couple hours ago regarding James commis
exoneration statement about the
Clinton's server investigation he's the
author of the best-selling book
vengeance former Speaker of the House
Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich okay
this is may mr. speaker
he hadn't interviewed Hillary Clinton or
at least 17 others key to the
investigation the fix is in I don't know
any other way to interpret it if you're
writing an exoneration before an
investigation look I think this is
unbelievable if you if you and I had sat
down and Bob viously very pro Trump but
if we'd both sat down and said two years
ago let's write a story in which the
head of the FBI consciously sets out to
protect Hillary Clinton no matter how
guilty she is consciously sets out to
protect her staff no matter how guilty
they are sets up everything so that even
his statements in public will exonerate
her we couldn't have made this up if it
is now clear first of all that if the if
Comey and the FBI done their job early
enough that you probably would have had
Bernie Sanders as the nominee because
Hillary couldn't have survived the
obvious news while the fix was that
there - she and her staff work when you
talk about the Clintons the fix was in
there - and we now know we know the fix
was that so so here's my point
you now have it then this is a very
serious question for the Congress and
frankly I think it puts an enormous
amount of pressure on the Attorney
General because I think attorney general
sessions has an absolute obligation to
look at this information and begin to
think about how they're going to
prosecute Comey and how they're going to
prosecute all of these other senior FBI
agents who clearly based on their their
their text messages back and forth and
including by the way I think a
great deal of as yet unreported guilt in
terms of the the chief deputy whose wife
had gotten I think nine hundred thousand
dollars from the Democrats and yet who
was still engaged in all this I mean you
have here a a cesspool of corruption
covering up for the Clintons in a way
which I would have to say as a historian
is unimaginable I know I do not know of
any point in American history where you
have this this level of a system of
corruption we've had occasional Attorney
General's we had one under Harding we
had one under grant when you go back and
find individuals who were crooks but
this level of constant methodical
undermining of the rule of law people
who thought it was their job to save
America I mean yeah this is when when
you talk about law enforcement officials
who decide they will impose their
version on the American people you're
telling us something very scary and
something which totally undermines the
American system Mr Speaker I want to get
into the specifics of this this is very
profound because on a level far deeper
than Watergate ever was here there is
corruption at the highest levels this is
no longer paranoia it's provable fact
that the fix was in here you have James
Comey then you have the pro-hillary
anti-trump Peter struck and then his
girlfriend Lisa Paige yeah they're the
ones that are going to save America with
what they're doing but this exoneration
of Hillary Clinton when you take out the
word likely foreign actors were able to
access her email account to cover up a
foreign a national security breach in
this country then when you take the
actual legal language gross negligence
and you remove that and put in and you
try to be cute and put an extreme
carelessness I don't even know what to
say I mean there's nothing wouldn't you
define this as the first obstruction
sorry okay there at every level
this is undermining our system of
justice it is violating the law
it's very likely all these people will
end up going to jail but imagine that
that the reverse had happened imagine
that they had allowed the law to follow
its natural course imagine that you'd
gotten a report last summer but over the
summer of 2016 by director Comey saying
well you know it's likely that foreign
agents did get to her accounts because
of the way she'd handle them and the way
she'd broken the rules it is clear that
she was guilty of gross negligence which
in fact is as a technical term meaning
that she had broken the law it's been if
he had said therefore I am recommending
that she be prosecuted I mean you would
have blown the whole campaign wide open
at that point you probably would have
had Trump winning with 55 or 60 percent
of the vote you'd have had a shattering
of the Democratic Party all of this is a
I mean I literally and I challenge
anybody in our audience to find me a
case where you have this kind of
methodical corruption this violation of
the rule of law at this level of
bureaucracy not the political appointees
at the very top but people who have
spent their career who are sworn to
uphold the law and and I think it's
maybe the greatest crisis in terms of
law and order and the rule of law in
American history the rule of law in
jeopardy